I have a very funny story about keeping
my eyes moist
nope still not getting that Vibe man
really oh Adrian in the back of your
gowns open Don't peek at my tushy wait
since when is your back covered in
tattoos it's not otherwise I couldn't
get buried in a Jewish cemetery are you
Jewish not yet oh I should ask that
nurse if they've got a moil on staff
wait maybe you've been getting tattoos
to help you remember things like the guy
in Memento again haven't seen it nope
the tattoos could be clues that you're
leaving for yourself here we'll step out
you get undressed and write down
everything you see and you're fully
naked all right well I guess we're
looking at them together okay this one
says buy toilet paper in a truly
gigantic font I hate to think of the
horrific event that led you a reminder
of this size this says your bank account
number is four three two two one one
three seven eight then just under that
someone saw this and stole your money
says don't trust your Deeds okay well
that's good advice my deed does get me
in a lot of trouble are you sure that's
what the d stands for oh it's for sure
my dong it could tell some stories Costa
Rica in 98 Nam and it's coming up oh no
there's a bob in my chest save yourself
no no it's just your little watch okay
means it's time for you to take your
pills you keep them in your right coat
pocket oh
okay
where's my code it's down on my car ah
I'll go get it you stay here no no your
penis is out I'll go okay
oh boy I love that little guy right
you know they claim that smoking is bad
for you but is there any medical
evidence to back that up great point so
the swedums foundation has really
accomplished a lot recently our
Healthcare outreach program has reduced
pink eye in the rural community by 30
percent
to 70 percent snooze
you guys ever been fox hunting I have my
own foxes flown in from Russia we drug
them pretty heavily so they can't get
very far in fact mostly they just flop
around on the ground makes it easier to
just walk up and bow
stupid foxes
it's deeply erotic that sounds amazing
we should go hunting sometime well I'd
love to I could bust out my Ralph Lauren
fall 2010 collection copped it in 2012.
clearance rack wear whatever you want as
long as it's not too bright or
reflective you know I want you blending
in to the surroundings how fast can you
run
if that guy wants to hunt me hi there
hello
Jalen who's that man this is my new
rebound boyfriend Derek I made him hi
I'm Derek you must be my
ah okay that makes more sense you must
be Michael Janet's made a lot of talk
talk into my ear Holes about you Michael
Michael kleichel clayco chanet you can't
make a person I know but I did though
Eleanor said that to forget about Jason
I should create a rebound guy so I made
one Derek oh I'm her boyfriend and she
made me he's so nice whoa look at this
glass oh my God
I'm in there too what's going on right
now it's my first time making someone so
he might be a little bit off look this
could be please put that down this could
be very dangerous it shouldn't even be
possible well maybe not 800 reboots ago
but apparently now it is
[Music]
Derek is it Derek it's Derek Derek could
you please give me and Janet a moment
alone go back to the void babe I'll be
there in a minute okay I'll miss you
like crazy I'll miss you more no
I'll miss you more bye
bye what a dork am I right
uh Jason Jason Jason Jason Jason Jason
Jason Jason Jason Jason Jason Jason
Jason
you've been heard loud and clear you
convinced me
JJ's can stay
good thing to say party
do you think I care about how much you
love this stupid Diner I bought it for a
song and I'm gonna sell it for a mint
and you can all just sit there pull it
on your puds oh yeah give me your booze
I am nourished by your hatred I should
also let you know you're all trespassing
on private property release the hounds
what hounds the hounds is an FDA
rejected cologne I've been working on
that makes everything smell like wet dog
make it red
[Laughter]
oh I gotta go kill my dad let's go
hey partner oh I've been waiting for you
sorry if I surprised you it's just when
I was Undercover the middle of the night
was the only time I could do actual
police work uh how'd you get in the
apartment oh it was easy I just seduced
the old lady upstairs came down the fire
escape Jimmy the window open Bing Bang
Boom I'm inside your living quarters
totally
of course next time you could just give
me a call you know two ways to pop in on
a friend I didn't kill the old lady
upstairs if that's what you're worried
about play him now oh wait a minute you
think I'm being weird
oh I shouldn't have come here this is
your apartment I'm so sorry Jake stupid
Paul stupid you idiot Bob hey pimento
who's Paul whoa
Paul's need was my undercover name okay
damn it Jake I don't know who I am
anymore you could have chose any name to
go undercover and you picked Paul Snead
it seems kind of crazy this was a
mistake I'm not ready I knew I wasn't
ready to go back to being police the
only job I've ever had except for a bag
of groceries at the supermarket at the
court of Atlantic and Clinton
I guess I could go back to that again
paper or plastic yeah still got it
listen to me I was undercover 63 days
with the mafia I saw some messed up
stuff I know what your struggle is and I
can bring you home but you've got to
trust me
great
gotta get some sleep
you're welcome to stay here and work the
case if you want thanks partner I
promise I won't disturb you at all
oh
papermento huh I thought you were just
gonna be looking through the files or
something man sorry brother Tai Chi
helps keep the demons at bay right
and
do you have to do it in your underwear I
can't take them off because then you'd
be looking right at my penis and
testicles
challenge who's that man this is my new
rebound boyfriend Derek I made him hi
I'm Derek you must be Mike oh okay that
makes more sense you must be Michael
Janet's made a lot of talk talk into my
ear Holes about you Michael Michael
Michael kleichel cycle kleiko Janet you
can't make a person I know but I did
though Eleanor said that to forget about
Jason I should create a rebound guy so I
made one Derek oh I'm her boyfriend and
she made me he's so nice whoa look at
this glass oh my God
I'm in there too what's going on right
now it's my first time making someone so
we might be a little bit off look this
could be please put that down this could
be very dangerous it shouldn't even be
possible well maybe not 800 reboots ago
but apparently now it is
[Music]
can you believe this Derek is it Derek
it's Derek Derek could you please give
me and Janet a moment alone go back to
the void babe I'll be there in a minute
okay I'll miss you like crazy I'll miss
you more no
I'll miss you more bye
bye what a dork am I right
uh Jason Jason Jason Jason Jason Jason
Jason Jason Jason Jason Jason Jason